so hello everybody i am here with robert
breedlove
robert was suggested to me on twitter i
kind of asked a question
who people thought i should talk to in
terms of crypto
and his name kind of came up on top he
is
the host of the the what is money show
that tries to explain this bitcoin to
stuff
he has a pass in finance and in crypto
and so
uh it seems like he's the guy to go to
and he he's already told me that he
thinks that there are ways to think
about this
and to understand understand this in a
symbolic way with a symbolic lens
so i'm really looking forward to finally
diving into bitcoin
and crypto with him thanks jonathan glad
to be here
oh it's my it's great to meet you and
i'm really looking forward because
i have like let me just say at the
outset which is that i have
a i have a kind of a suspicion about
bitcoin
and i can't explain i can't totally
explain it and
it probably has to do with my uh
experience which i kind of related
off-camera before a little bit with you
which is that
i was involved i wasn't involved someone
that i trust and that i respect
set me up with uh with a crypto account
which was called steams like this
attention
coin um and uh you know then you kept
telling me you need to
you need to make sure you've got a
whatever it's called an account where
you
like an exchange it got a wallet account
and i didn't know what he was talking
about so i just kind of followed the
steps set this thing up on quadringa
and then i lost everything within a day
which because the
ceo died we're not even sure some people
think he pretended to die
so all the money just vanished um and
what's been interesting is actually i
i didn't really get involved in the
proceeds of that but i
started getting emails from uh lawyers
about
like you know disinterring the corpse
and
trying to figure out if he was really
dead it was really
it was really fascinating just to
actually follow how
kind of mad and insane the whole
discussion uh got
uh and i'm noticing like all the
craziness with dogecoin
and just how mad it is in terms of
almost like a meme coin
which is happening so all of that is
making me wonder what the heck is going
on
uh and also i i'm trying to kind of
grasp to understand and try to be
as uh open and as positive as possible
to try to understand what's going on so
hopefully
you can help to shed a light on what
crypto is and what bitcoin means that
there's a symbolism
yeah big task that i'm putting i'm
putting on your plate there
robert no no pressure at all no pressure
um
i think you're you're drawing attention
to one of the main
elements of of this crypto asset space
uh which is we have bitcoin
and then we have everything else and
everything else especially in martin
like right now we're in a bull market so
bitcoin is increasing in price
everything else is correlated to bitcoin
so it's increasing in price
that creates a lot of noise and
confusion it draws in a lot of
new people and capital and attention and
you get this
confluence of just a false narratives i
guess you would say
so the one you mentioned steam that was
intended to be a decentralized social
media tool
i believe um and it's
okay it's a good theory it's good on
paper but it doesn't have any like
market proven utility
so for instance the last time we were in
a bull market
this is the tends to run in four year
cycle so this was 2017.
there were people just putting up a
website a white paper
a few pictures of advisors and they
would go and raise
30 million dollars worth of bitcoin and
ethereum in five minutes
like it was the the most the fastest
and uh most rich capital raising
environment probably in the history of
humanity you can literally just put up a
website and raise a ton of money
um so in this world the way i like to
distinguish between them is that
we have bitcoin which is this innovation
akin to the internet itself in many ways
you can think of it as the latest layer
in the internet protocol suite so the
internet evolved in layers
some of them you're familiar with http
tcp
etc um that were essentially
a it's a layered protocol for moving
information without permission
across space and time but the one thing
that it lacked was the ability to move
value economic value across space and
time without permission
that's what bitcoin adds to the internet
so bitcoin it fits right on top of the
internet
it is it is part and parcel of it
all of these other coins people call
them altcoins uh
more pejoratively people call them [ __ ]
coins um
they are essentially copying the code of
bitcoin
and trying to use it to either compete
with bitcoin directly as money or to
disintermediate other marketplaces
so the the line that i draw as i say
bitcoin
is the internet all other alt coins are
liquid venture capital
subjected to little if any due diligence
so
um that's also part of the internet
isn't it though like that's
part of what the in the internet also is
this there is an aspect of the internet
you know
the kind of not necessary there is the
dark web but not necessarily just a dark
web but just this
kind of madness of of
information right the idea that because
everything is so decentralized
the lack of authority means that you
know multiple narratives can fragment
you know infinite indefinitely
and it's and because you don't have an
authority structure you don't know
what's real and what's not you can't you
i don't have a way to legitimize
something even a business online it's
hard to know like
how do you legitimize you see someone
selling something online
you know how do you legitimize this
transaction it's hard to know
yeah yeah that's a great point that you
know information itself
suffers from unlimited replicability can
be replicated
at infinitum so there's it's hard to
find source of truth
in the digital world and that's what
that's another thing bitcoin has done
like it is it's established a
proof-of-work money
which means it's a money premise on
sacrifice
so it actually brings qualities of
physical reality
like final settlement which is very
important to money into digital reality
and that is it's the only
you hear this term thrown around a lot
blockchain crypto assets it's the only
market proven use case for blockchain is
bitcoin
everything else is just again venture
capital it's just an idea
and so i think it's very important to
distinguish between the two and the
other uh
the other bright line between them is
that bitcoin
is the only money in the world that no
one can control
you could say gold fit the bill
historically like that's why gold was
selected as money was kind of an
apolitical
money that no one could artificially
increase the supply of so it was it was
a reliable store of value
bitcoin has now become that for digital
space
uh whereas all of the other alt coins
are controlled by someone whether it's a
developer
community uh an executive board
um or anything else they have not
achieved what this critical property of
decentralization
that's really important to the power
structure of money so bitcoin
so the idea is that bitcoin it by its
own
process like it's controlled by its own
reality let's say or it's all that's
right
right it doesn't no one can no one can
clamp down and decide how many bitcoin
there are
it's part of the very process of bitcoin
to to kind of
lay itself out you know on its own let's
say yeah there's this
path dependent emergence that bitcoin's
gone through where it was just
it was released as the first of its kind
into the world it was a
first and only crypto asset it was
considered a joke initially by most
people you know they just
thought it was a joke which gave it time
to grow organically and gave its mining
network and developer community time to
grow organically
gave time for its rules to ossify
and it now you know it's a trillion
dollar market and for all intents and
purposes
uh there's no way to to stop it or
disrupt it
um and the the other thing that is
important is that it's
it's perfected the properties of money
so these other coins that are claiming
to be better
in one way or another they don't
actually address
the five properties of money which are
divisibility durability recognizability
portability scarcity
so bitcoin has essentially taken all of
the properties that make money good and
perfected them
and so satoshi in doing that he left no
design space
left for another crypto asset to come
and disrupt bitcoin
um and then just to talk back to your
particular
circumstances where you got uh knocked
over on the exchange
that's another area of common
misconception people hear about all
these exchanges getting hacked and all
these scams and people launching these
coins and disappearing with the money
and they conflate all of that with
bitcoin they think bitcoin is getting
hacked they think bitcoin is stealing
their money
um and it couldn't be further from the
truth bitcoin is
is operated with perfect fidelity over
12 years
it's grown already to be the most secure
computing network
in human history never been hacked
there's never been any unexpected
inflation no double spending
but everything else in and around the
space is like the scammiest
dirtiest um space in the world so it's
it's hard for people i think to
disentangle the two
we have this world shattering innovation
that's disruptive to gold
right gold's a tool we've been using for
5 000 years is money
there's a 12 year old digital disruptor
emerging
against gold but it's surrounded in this
cloud of scams and
you know people trying to just get rich
quick schemes i guess people are right
so what it so what so when you say that
it's it's never been hacked it's never
been
uh you know what is it about the system
which makes it that way
like what is there which makes it
impervious to these problems
it's really uh it's a beautiful
composite
of design and incentives so
on the design side it's a very
simplistic set of computer
code really just designed to do two
things which is
create a new block of transactions every
10 minutes
and maintain a supply cap of 21 million
so it's the first asset in human history
we know has an absolutely
fixed supply it's an incorruptible money
it's a money that no one can change
um and there's a bit of a a rabbit hole
there but
it's essentially the corruption of the
money has been the chosen
the chosen attack vector for all state
powers throughout history
they always clip the coins they always
inflate the bills it's free money right
it's this temptation that no one has
ever been able to resist
and for the first time in history we
have a mod and gold was
great at that historically because no
one could just artificially increase the
supply of gold
but once we abstracted gold into paper
currency people started to manipulate
gold as well
and central banking today they own about
20 of the gold supply
and corrupt the world by by doing so
bitcoin is this emergent incorruptible
monetary base layer for human
organization
um and it's something unlike we've ever
seen
and the incentive side to it and this is
the
it takes a bit of time to get your head
around it but bitcoin essentially
incentivizes
everyone who interacts with it to
operate
in its favor so if you're mining bitcoin
you're you're expending energy to secure
the network
and you're being paid in bitcoin if
you're
buying or selling bitcoin you have a
money that is becoming
increasingly scarce over time so its
supply is diminishing
so for instance in the past 12 months
we've been producing us dollars for 108
years in the past 12 months
one out of every three dollars in
existence was produced in the past 12
years
so we have the where as the us dollar uh
inflation rate is going absolutely
parabolic
bitcoin's doing the opposite bitcoin
becomes harder to produce over time
so therefore the dollar price expressed
the dollar price of bitcoin becomes more
expensive over time
the the simple way i like to say is that
bitcoin is an insurance policy
on central banking the more dollars that
we print
the more valuable that insurance policy
becomes
um and this so that's what makes it
interesting is that bitcoin has
incorporated human nature or darwinian
self-preservation as one of its core
operating components
that it's actually incentivizing you to
secure its network incentivizing you to
hold it
um and incentivizing you to sell your
dollars and buy it
so you can think of it as like this this
vortex of incentives that no one has
figured out how to stop
and traditionally when these networks
just using kind of like facebook apple
amazon netflix google
as a proxy when these networks get above
100 billion
in market cap they're pretty much
unstoppable
bitcoin's already 10 times that size
bitcoin's a trillion dollar market today
so it it appears that it is one of the
most significant innovations
of our lives possibly even bigger than
the internet itself
all right so what so one of the things
that because i've been thinking about
this trying to figure it out because
obviously i don't understand the
technical aspects of it and
and i probably never will which might be
fine um
one of the things that makes something
valuable like you name the five
aspects of money and the what was
surprised to me that i didn't hear in
that is something
like trust um
because trust is something which is
beyond the the system
um and and a trust is responded like
in a monetary system in a traditional
monetary system
trust is related to authority that is i
trust in the money system
because i recognize the authority that's
why there was a stamp of the king on the
coin
is because the stamp of the king tells
me
that this is what it says it is right
and that this
has value let's say
and so one of the things that happened
with bitcoin in the past
20 years is that at some point it
dropped to nearly nothing
right like there was a massive
crash i don't remember the it's been
through four market cycles
right giant run-up and giant crash yeah
and so and so that to me like that
extreme
those extremes although
although i could understand that they're
maybe not as bad as those other cryptos
that you talk about like that these kind
of
crap coins or whatever you call them you
know there it seems like
the fact that it doesn't have
it doesn't have authority
that in moment in a moment of panic then
it can become nothing like it can go
from everything to nothing
i don't know if that makes sense that it
doesn't have meaning like it doesn't
have meaning
it doesn't participate in a web of
meaning
so the trust factor of money
i would argue it actually coalesces to
those properties
so the the very nature of value itself
is value is the relevance of a thing
to our goals right whatever closes the
gap
between my wishes and their fulfillment
is valuable to me
anything that blocks that process is
destructive to value anything that
is irrelevant is just value-less right
so values this inherently subjective
quality of existence quality of being
um and and you know we look at the world
through a lens of value things to us or
either obstacles or tools
getting us on our way or blocking us
along that path
so historically
gold was the tool that best satisfied
those properties of money
and that's why over an entire history of
entrepreneurial experimentation
the free market selected gold as money
it was the most
divisible durable recognizable portable
and scarce thing in the world so we
could say gold
earned the trust of market participants
without
any authority being involved whatsoever
you could say the authority of god
perhaps right gold was governed by
the laws of chemistry and nature such
that its supply could not be
artificially increased
it's essentially indestructible so it
had a very high
stock to flow ratio which is another way
of saying it did not inflate quickly its
supply increased about two percent year
over year
so if you parked your wealth in gold you
knew
you could trust you had a lot of
confidence that your wealth would only
be inflated about two percent every year
no matter what anyone tried to do
right no matter what law government
passed or anything that happened in the
sphere of politics
and human affairs nothing could change
that so it was a trusted
base layer so i don't think
authority and that would be my point
there with gold is that you don't need
authority to establish trust
what you need is time and
experimentation
right what what what tool
solves uh the aim for people and the aim
with money is to move
your economic value or wealth across
space and time
so what holds its value across time
that's what's first and foremost
and then secondly what can be used to
transact that value across space with
other
market actors um and then one of the
things gold has that
bitcoin doesn't have is that you can use
gold to make a crown
right you can use gold to make you can
use gold to make an
altar or you can use gold to make a
throne which
actually marginalizes its monetary use
case
i would say because dedicated to
something higher
that's one of the reasons why i'm saying
that it that's how it gets its authority
because it's shiny and it and it gets
dedicated up
but it gets offered to god you could say
so
this is correct this is how gold so
another way to understand money and by
the way this is why
the show is called the what is money
show because this question has a million
answers
um money another definition of money is
that it is the most
exchangeable or tradable or liquid asset
in a trade network so if you go into a
prison today
very often they use cigarettes as
currency right that's just the most
tradable asset that they have access to
and it best satisfies those properties
so it is it is money in that trade
network by definition
um so gold
emerges as the most tradable thing
because it satisfies those properties
but
it was only ever traded in the first
place because it had industrial use
making a crown building an altar built
what jewelry
dental electronics whatever this is and
still today
gold has a market cap of like 10
trillion dollars about 10 to 20 percent
of that
is its industrial use so it's its use as
non-money anything gold can do this
non-monetary there's a demand for that
so we could say the entire configuration
of demand for gold is part industrial or
utility
use and part monetary use
and in in that lens it has it has a
story
it has a story use like a mythological
reality yes
like it's the head of the statue of
nebuchadnezzar it's the
you know it's the the first age is the
golden age it's the
it has it has a memory like in terms of
of
humanity that we can't get rid of like
people
think like i've heard people say things
like if we all agree that gold wouldn't
be
worth anything then it would that it
would stop that's not how it works
right because that memory is deeply
ingrained in
in all of our stories from all the fairy
tales all our myths all their stories
have
let's say something like gold silver and
the other precious metals
as part of the of a of a
collective memory you could say yes
absolutely they
they have been proven over time to serve
this purpose
but with that process you have a
a bivalent money a money that's part
used in industry and part used as money
and through that same lens this is
another reason why bitcoin is radically
new and i liked
you you talked about the virgin
archetype in one of your podcasts
recently where the virgin is something
that is purely dedicated to one purpose
right it's untainted by any other
purpose
it has one sole focus essentially
bitcoin is the first virgin money it's
the only money that is
all of its market capitalization is for
its monetary use case
you cannot make a crown out of bitcoin
you cannot make a throne
or put it in your teeth or whatever yeah
it's close to pure potential you could
say
as close as possible it's the most
purified monetary technology that has
ever existed
it's perfected all the properties of
money and it has no alternative use case
whatsoever
and in in terms of to get back to your
point on coinage
coinage actually emerged initially as a
private
business function so when people would
trade with gold
you needed to weigh the gold you needed
to say it you needed to make sure it was
authentic
yeah trust yeah trump trust that it was
real the real thing
exactly you needed to make sure it
wasn't lead coded in gold etc
so every time you exchanged gold you had
to go through this time intensive
process
that increased transaction cost and was
a friction to free trade basically
in comes the the coinage function
where a private certifier would instead
stamp these gold coins
saying you can trust this stamp you know
can you trust me
you trust me so you can trust this stamp
that's right you're replacing the
reputation of the coinage
issuer with the need to say the gold and
if that
if it's ever incorrect then you go after
the coinage issuer yeah well that issuer
became more and more centralized and
controlled by the state over time
in almost every society around the world
and that's why we always end up with
these
smug emperor or dead president faces on
all of our money
um they're they're trying to actually
insert
belief or uh trust in the state
right as being the bearer of that
commonwealth
but what they've actually done is just
commandeer a free market function
and again to look at bitcoin through
that lens
if you you run your own node that's why
you run your own node in bitcoin which
means you're running your own
independent history of bitcoin with
every transaction so you don't need to
trust anyone
you are your own central bank if you
will or your own coinage issuer
you can verify with 100 certainty and
zero percent trust
that the bitcoin you are receiving is in
fact authentic bitcoin
yeah um and that's a game changer as
well
yeah and i think it's like i i get it i
i understand like the image you use of
the idea of the virgin uh
and also the the notion that money is in
a way potentiality right it's the
yes the dissolution of your goals or
you know it's like it's the dissolution
of your goals whether it's buying
something objects or services or
whatever you know into a potentiality
that you can then redirect towards
different things like that's what money
seems to be at least especially in the
modern
world um and so
this is to me like this is this is the
key that i was trying to get to
before and you probably won't agree with
me but it seems like the fact that
that's what it is means that it's either
everything or nothing
that it's either that it's either it
will have it will like you said
it will reach massive amounts of value
or it will have me mean that
be worth nothing because it doesn't
participate
doesn't have a kind of gritty hierarchy
in it
which is the goal like the like like you
said the
the gold is not pure value in the sense
of pure potential
it it also can be used to make things
and so because of that
it's like worse comes to worse
right worse comes to worse if i have a
an iron bar it has a value but i can
also use it to make
a sword right i can use it to make
something uh you know if i have a stack
of wood
it's maybe will never be worth as much
as bitcoin but i can use it to make a
cabin
whereas if bitcoin because it's just
pure value
that seems to me at least to account for
its like
huge uh up and down um
but i mean like what do you think do you
think that now that there won't be
another down or it's just gonna keep
going up
well so i guess first of all to speak
about the volatility
bitcoin has been through four as i
mentioned earlier four of these price
cycles yeah
so just a quick
history i guess from uh mid 2015 to late
2017
bitcoin went from 200 to 20 000. so did
a 100x
and two and a half years it then came
down 85 percent
over the course of the year to 3500
so now we're in another bull market
it's close to around 60 000 so it's up
20 x off of that low
roughly um and we would expect this bull
market to peak
somewhere later this year but this
volatility is occurring
volatility itself it exists it's
i've said that volatility is truth so
we say the the universe is pervaded by
entropy
right it's everything's changing
everything's tending towards increasing
disorder with these little
pockets of order here and there that is
expressed as volatility price volatility
in the marketplace
bitcoin is the fastest growing asset in
human history today it's gone from zero
dollars
in economic value 12 years ago to one
trillion dollars
in economic value today that path
could not possibly be linear um
it's been driven by its having cycle
so every four years the new supply
issuance of bitcoin gets cut in half
and if you just hold you know prices
supply and demand so if you're holding
demand
constant and you cut supply in half what
happens to price
right price gets a lot of upward
pressure um
and it tends to overshoot right it goes
maybe it's actual value you could say
which is say let's define price as an
appraisal of value
right so you say value is tracking some
fundamental utility of of bitcoin as
money whereas its price is just what
it's trading for in the marketplace
so as its value increases over time its
price is overshooting and undershooting
that value along the way
that is the volatility of bitcoin
um and it does the other thing
to that point is this is true of all
assets this is not just bitcoin
yeah but not not to the levels that
we're seeing right amazon's more
volatile
been more volatile in bitcoin in its
early years amazon drew down 94
on the dot-com bus it had double-digit
drawdowns every single year
the past 20 years it's up 45 000 off its
lows
so volatility and market cap are
inversely proportionate and this also
applies to bitcoin
so the bigger bitcoin is becoming the
less volatile it's becoming over time
but this narrative by the way is being
pumped so hard by mainstream media
bitcoin is a ponzi scheme bitcoin is too
volatile
like it is blasting from every channel
on mainstream media
but it's just i would argue these
these media channels that are controlled
and serving the interest of central
banking
propagandizing against a technology that
is disruptive to their business model
yeah what's happening so here's the
question so like here are a few
questions that i've got when i when i
when i
when i'm hearing what you're saying and
so
there are two things that come to mind
um one is so
so for example what is the problem of
the internet
and the problem of this this
potentiality so
one of the things that happens when
something presents itself as a wild
potentiality
you know uh and the internet is an
example of that
where the internet presented itself at
first and still
a little bit now as
infinite possibility right no borders
no authority you know total
almost anarchy of discussion anarchy of
possibility anything can happen
anything is possible um
and that was that that's kind of how it
was presented to us right in the late
90s
and now we could say the opposite of
that we could say
the internet is the system of control
the most total system of control
that has ever been invented in human
history
that that there are si that that social
media these systems that are out there
are able to read your thoughts are able
to predict your movements
know everything that you're going to do
everything you're thinking um
and are trying to direct that
ideologically
in ways that has never happened in the
entire history of humanity right
and so what i'm trying to bring about is
that
the idea of like pure potentiality what
it calls for
it's almost like it's calling for a
master
and so it's it's like if you
the real world is like a balance between
potentiality and actuality like the real
world is this
this kind of this ebb and flow this like
normal masculine feminine
these the these this kind of
relationship between opposites
but when you present something which is
like chaos
then it's it's like it's asking it's not
it's creating a tantalizing thing for
order to kind of clamp down upon so it's
kind of like a riot a riot
what comes after a riot is police and
not just regular police
riot police that come with guns and with
with things that they usually don't use
right if if anarchy breaks out then more
authority is put on it in order to
clamp it down and so you could say you
don't like that which
whatever it doesn't matter it's still
going to happen right
because that's it's almost like it's
part of the system
um and so when i look at what's going on
with crypto it's weird like my intuition
and i may be wrong because i don't
understand the technical part of it
but when i look at what's happening with
crypto
i see i intuit that there's also a
movement towards
a hyper-controlled world currency that
will be
a totalizing currency and that if you
don't use that currency
you won't actually be able to trade at
all and so it's not right now
it's not here it's not totally there but
there is this
it's like it's like there's an intuition
that i have that i can see it on the
horizon just like i could see
in the internet you know even 10 years
ago i could see that
this is moving towards a system of
control
yeah first on the topic of
free speech the internet promised to be
this great democratizing force
giving all of us the ability to just
exchange ideas freely which in a lot of
ways it's given us
many tools to that effect but it's also
been monopolized right these platforms
are controlled that we have the
emergence of data monopolies the fang
stocks etc
um that monetize our data and our
attention
bitcoin there's a promise in bitcoin and
this hasn't completely emerged yet but
because bitcoin is an immutable
protocol on the internet stack
there is the possibility now and we're
already seeing it at higher layers
uh in both what's called the lightning
network was which is a layer on top of
bitcoin and applications built on the
lightning network
uh particularly one i'm thinking of
called sphynx chat
that enable unstoppable free speech and
social media tools
so you can actually anchor these tools
into the bitcoin blockchain such that
they cannot be censored
so the the just let's just say on the
horizon
is this glimmering hope of an
uncensorable internet
built on top of bitcoin so that's one
great feature that's still
kind of on the horizon but but it's
possibly emerging
i would argue too that bitcoin it
actually introduces
a disciplinary force to the chaos of the
internet
uh that's really that's actually why
proof of work was originally invented
it was invented to inhibit email spam
so instead of just spamming you know
every email address in the world with
you know countless solicitation or
marketing or scam emails
this system of proof-of-work uh
created a mechanism by which each one of
those would cost you just a little bit
so that would really dis-incentivize
spam so it would incentivize
it gives people that want to communicate
via the internet it gives them skin in
the game there's a cost associated with
their communication so therefore
their communications become more
authentic and honest
um so i think bitcoin can introduce that
to the internet by actually forcing by
making messages unsensible but also
causing allowing people to be able to
gate um
you know what they receive and then also
force people that want to communicate to
pay up
basically reduces spam and then i would
say that
uh your intuition on the movement
towards one world
totalitarian or authoritarian currency
is very likely
i think that race has already begun
between kind of china the us
and the the extension of the us which
are the imf and the world bank
they are racing to have a counter
measure against bitcoin
because bitcoin is it's perfect
i'll use perfect in quotation marks
because nothing's perfect but it's
perfected the properties of money it's
disrupting
gold and with it their institution of
systemized
time theft which is the central bank you
know we hear about all this money
in the world being printed very few of
us understand that no new wealth is
being created
as a result of printing that money yeah
we're just shifting the claims on
capital from one set of hands to another
so it's systemized theft at scale
uh central banking is at best a
misguided
institution at worst it's the greatest
criminal enterprise in human history
yet no one's talking about it no one
understands it um
it's above politics by the way it's it's
politics is the puppet show that central
banks put on to distract us from the
truth
and i would say that the counter measure
that they do take against bitcoin
whether it's the imf
or the fed coin or whatever it may be
there's going to be a money
that's forced upon us they're going to
cancel physical cash
they're going to say you have to turn in
all your physical cash to get us fed
coin
and you're going to l that money will
live inside a walled garden
and they can turn it off and they can
turn it on they can choose what you
spend it on
if they don't like what you're saying
online they could turn off your money
completely
we'll move into this world of something
much more like a china social credit
score system
where if you're not playing friendly
with the state's ideology
they will dial up or dial down your
ability to use money
travel everything and in that world
of this orwellian world of total
censorship and control i think
bitcoin is the only answer it's a money
that no one can control no one can
censor
no one can weaponize right to steal from
others
um so that's the big battle here
it's about its own authoritarianism and
the free market
so so the image of bitcoin and the image
of crypto i guess
is a like it is in a way a stampless
currency like it doesn't have the stamp
of authority it's
it really is this kind of it's dark in
the good and bad sense right in the
sense that
you can't know like if you are if you
have bitcoin and you have it like you
said
then you've got it that's it like no one
can take it from you
right uh unless they actually take the
you know the number like your whatever
code or whatever i don't know how it
works but whatever it is that they would
physically steal from you like once you
once you've got it then you've got it so
this is the
so because it's dark it also has it it
has a
has a negative aspect in the sense that
you don't know who owns the bitcoin
right
and so what happens what happens in 10
years
when all of a sudden we discover that
the chinese government and the central
banks actually own
85 or 90 percent of bitcoin
and we didn't know but now we find out
because we don't know who owns it
like couldn't the bitcoin itself because
it's
those who own it who will have power so
what's being set up is like a secret
elite of power
that we don't know who it is like
there's this massive amount of value
that exists in the dark that we don't
know who has it
and so what happens when we discover
that it's actually
the same agents that we that we want to
get away from that actually own the most
of bitcoin
um i think it's pretty unlikely that
they could ever own
85 to 95 i don't know like i'm just
saying number one
i mean the only way they could do that
is you'd have to monetize all the
central bank balance sheets into bitcoin
so bitcoin's market cap would be 100
trillion dollars or more
um so in that event if you're holding
bitcoin you're going to be wildly rich
uh it would also again it although it's
unlikely if that happened it's still a
better outcome for humanity
because the the core premise here is
that the integrity of the money supply
and the integrity of society are
inexorably linked
if the money supply can be violated and
changed arbitrarily then social cohesion
can collapse
and the extreme example of that is just
hyperinflation like look what's going on
in venezuela today
talk about having no meaning the money
literally has no meaning it's in the
gutters it's in the streets
people are pushing it around in a
wheelbarrow trying to buy a loaf of
bread
the money has been inflated into
worthlessness so it's this
concept of unexpected inflation that is
positively correlated to
a breakdown in social cooperation
bitcoin's the only money in history this
is
again what it optimizes for a hard cap
of 21 million
it has zero percent unexpected inflation
when you understand you get past the
central bank euphemism that inflation is
necessary for a healthy economy
you realize that it's just purely theft
integrated into the money
this is the only way to
optimize trust in a society so it's
we're we're moving from trust and
authority to trust and self-interest
that's what bitcoin does it's you're
trusting the self-interest of every
other market actor
and what else is there to trust in a
darwinian world other than self-interest
you have to trust that everyone's going
to operate in their own self-interests
yeah but like the free market
that that paradoxically creates the
these selfless outcomes from individual
pursuit of self-interest bitcoin's the
same
it's a free market money that i by
choosing to hold my bitcoin
and secure my wealth independently and
verify my wealth independently
i'm actually voting against this system
of time theft that the central bank
represents
and therefore voting for something more
positive for humanity
yeah i mean it how can i say this it's
like i understand it because i also
think that
the monetary system the way it's been
set up in modernity and the way that
it's been
completely um taken away from a standard
and it's just
it's just total speculation i think
that's an insane thing it's an
it's an insane thing that is leading us
to catastrophe
um but i nonetheless like
the arbitrariness of bitcoin in the
sense that okay
so let's say i don't like the fact that
states
rule over me and that the states have
this power
um but i would prefer
that the states rule over me and have
power than some shady person that i
don't know who that person is
and has massive amounts of bitcoin like
imagine a world where bitcoin replaces
money that means that all of a sudden
these shadowy actors are going to start
to appear
as being the most powerful and it's
going to be purely arbitrary
it can be totally arbitrary it's not
going to be someone who
built a network or built uh
you know like i can't hate jeff bezos
all i want but he built a real thing
like a company and he's got he built
this thing i can
i can't hate the the you know i can hate
the government of a country but they run
the roads and they
they run this system whereas this is
what i was trying to bring up before
it's like
in bitcoin what you have is a shadowy
elite that is
that is hidden we don't know who these
people are and if it replaces money
i'm not sure that would be the best
outcome for humanity because all of a
sudden
they're going to start to appear like we
don't see them now but at some point
they're going to start to show
themselves when they become the most
powerful
people in the world also
one thing there is who do you think runs
the central banks today
there's already a shadow elite that runs
yeah you're right
but the trade one for another well
here's the key difference
the current shadowy elite yeah control
the rules
that govern money they want to steal
more from everyone
print more money they want to they want
to de-authorize people they
it is a totalitarian regime whereas
even if you gave that those same
individuals if you just switched out
their current
system for a bitcoin system they would
no longer have control over the system
they can't change the rules of bitcoin
bitcoin is a game
with unbreakable and unchangeable rules
and therefore it incentivizes people to
adopt
long-term peaceful cooperation as the
optimal strategy because you can't steal
from one another
right today a great strategy to get
wealthy today in the us
is to get as close to the fiat currency
printing press as possible
get a buddy in politics or get some
favorable regulation or get a bailout or
get a ppp loan or whatever
it's a great way to get free money and
steal from everyone else yeah
none of that is possible on a bitcoin
system you can't change it you can't
bail it out you can't manipulate it in
any way
so it's i would argue and this is
a tricky perspective shift is that we
actually
have to look at the systems we're
pouring ourselves into
i think the our personalities and our
characters are emergent properties of
the incentive structures we are
operating within
and right now we're operating within a
flawed incentive structure
which is like we can just print money
and steal from everyone else that's
forced to use the money
and this perverts morality this this
perverts social cohesion
and it leads to civilizational collapse
if you just look across
history and create civilization there's
ever been they break the money and then
they collapse
yeah yeah yeah the same pattern
repeatedly so we need a money that
cannot be corrupted
and that's bitcoin is the only thing
that exists that can't be corrupted
i mean i i i need to think about it i
definitely need to think about it i
think that you've
you've helped me at least understand
what it is
like understand what's going on
understand what it is i think i
i how can i say this i remain
with the two questions not the questions
but the two
the two issues i have in terms of of
actual
value right and how actual value appears
in terms of these extremes of of price
um and we'll see what's going to happen
because like you said
i think the issue the reason why i'm not
i don't object to it completely let's
say bitcoin is because i can see like
like you said how insane
our authorities are acting like just how
mad
the the the system is right now and how
it does in fact seem to be heading
towards
some kind of collapse which will be
recuperated into a
more totalitarian uh system
um and so and so i but i'm not sure
like you know in a real collapse like in
a real
in a real collapse like would bitcoin
continue to
have value well
it all depends on first of all like we
saw in march 2020
in the short run everyone runs to
dollars and treasuries still that's
still the safe haven
asset in the world or gold even yeah but
after that shock central banks respond
by printing more money
so what we see with bitcoin bitcoin
collapsed march 2020 down to 3 800
and now it's grown 20 x roughly in the
14 months since so again
it's all about this ratio of how many
dollars the rate of production of
dollars
the ratio of that to the rate of
production of bitcoin that's what
drives the price of bitcoin so if we
have these short-term economic shocks
bitcoin can suffer but then on the back
side of that bitcoin is going to expand
a lot as we print more dollars and just
to answer that
the one last point of your question
before was
you know bezos is a great example of an
amazing entrepreneur right he's created
so much additional productivity for the
world that's why he's rich
like we can strip out some of the the
arbitrage maybe where he kind of skirted
state taxes and a few of these things
right because he's operating with a
digital network versus a physical
network
but overall that's what entrepreneurship
is it's people going out into the world
solving problems selling those solutions
into the marketplace
everyone benefits as a result we become
more wealthy and more productive as a
result
on a bitcoin standard where i said
earlier the fiat there's a lot of
strategies related to getting near the
fiat currency spigot to get wealthy
on a bitcoin standard all you can do is
be an entrepreneur
that's the only way you can earn money
you can invest intelligently or you can
go out and solve problems for humanity
so i think we'll just unleash the the
the
power of human ingenuity on all the
unsolved problems specifically related
to the environment
um and we didn't even get into energy
which is a whole other very interesting
topic with bitcoin
if we want to decarbonize the atmosphere
we have the technology for that today
the problem is that it's too energy
intensive
bitcoin mining is a perpetual bounty
program for entrepreneurs to seek out
cheaper
and stranded energy sources so we now
have this global incentive to push
energy costs lower
right will in turn make decarbonization
more economically viable
and desalination right because water is
another issue but hey
if we can get desalination cheap enough
we can drink ocean water
so there's this whole again this vortex
of incentives that i refer to as bitcoin
as i don't know what else to call it
it's a brand new game
that's purely voluntary purely
transparent
and i would argue i mean i guess
it's still out for debate but i would
argue it's purely a net benefit for
humanity
like the trade-offs that it makes
optimize for individual sovereignty
individual optionality and individual
freedom i think
instilling those characteristics into
market actors is what creates the best
outcomes for all
yeah look i will definitely i will
definitely think about it i appreciate
your time
um and you know like i would say people
go
go into the comment section like i'm
learning about this and so
i will definitely be paying more
attention to the comment section seeing
you know your thoughts about what robert
is talking about you know your
objections to my objections
um and we're gonna we're gonna keep this
discussion going i'm gonna keep thinking
and i probably will be
talking about bitcoin uh a few more
times to try to wrap my head around it
as well
so thanks for your time robert i really
appreciate it yeah glad to be here and
so where can we point people to in terms
of seeing what you're working on
yeah i'm on on twitter at breedlove22
it's b r double e d l o v e 2 2 um and
then the youtube
the sorry the website for the podcast is
what is moneypodcast.com and it's also
on youtube
and i encourage people that's why i
again named it the what is money show
it's like you don't have to trust me i
know i speak emphatically about this
i've been studying it for five years
non-stop i feel strongly about it but
trust yourself go out and ask the
question
what is money and i promise you if you
follow that question deep enough
you're gonna unveil a lot of very
interesting truths about the world
yeah especially now and i think it is
definitely even in terms of symbolism
understanding what is money what is
credit
what is interest all of these things are
are subjects that i
that i'm i definitely want to put more
attention into because
they're crucial to understand and to to
see where we're going so thanks for
thanks again for your time robert
yeah thank you so much for having me all
right